oggi voglio condividere con voi in
dubbio lo vedete qui una domanda ed è
una domanda che mi riguarda da cittadino
e da professionista da consulente
politico cioè se lavoro che stiamo
facendo noi come consulenti politici da
comunicare la politica le istituzioni
del comunicare se stessa è un lavoro che
sta facendo del bene alle persone oppure
no è la domanda che mi pongo da dieci
anni la quando iniziato che a quando
iniziato e ho iniziato con i social
media fare questo mestiere con la band
nei social media
tutti quanti ci siamo detti questi
strumenti aumenteranno gli spazi di
democrazia faranno parlare di più le
persone saranno più possibilità
vinceranno i buoni dieci anni dopo se
vogliamo fare un primo bilancio forse le
cose non sono andate esattamente così o
non sono andate sempre così quindi o da
consulente politico e da cittadino mi
sono chiesta gli chiedo costantemente se
le cose stanno andando bene oppure no e
ragionando su questa domanda ho trovato
dei campanelli d'allarme
il primo è la notizia di qualche giorno
fa
facebook sta sperimentando in australia
un'infrastruttura in cui il mi piace
sotto i posti
spariscono non ci sono più e qualcosa in
italia anche successo e chi di voi ha
instagram
chi di voi si è accorto che da qualche
settimana sotto i post dei vostri amici
sono spariti mi piace chi di voi sa
perché accaduto c'è qualcuno a tutti gli
altri racconto il motivo il motivo è
nella parola che la gente in alto a
sinistra che in italiano viene tradotta
tivo contarello demetric azione cioè
vuol dire che in questo momento facebook
e instagram che fanno parte della stessa
famiglia degli strumenti sono i questi
questi sono queste infrastrutture sono
in corso delle sperimentazioni per
verificare cosa succede nel
comportamento degli utenti se facciamo
scomparire like mi piace e mi piace che
sono stati la moneta
con cui questi imperi digitali si sono
arricchiti da un certo punto oggi sono
messi in discussione perché sono messi
in discussione sono lesse discussione e
quindi potrebbero essere un problema lo
scopriremo nei prossimi mesi perché
qualche anno fa e da qui nasce una
storia che ripeto oggi è visibile ma che
negli anni è stato oggetto di numerose
discussioni intellettuali qualche ne fa
un ricercatore del dc calo ben gross ha
creato uno strumento con cui faceva
navigare gli utenti sui propri motori di
ricerca sui propri browser in una
piattaforma in cui i like sparivano
potevano scegliere se navigare con
facebook con i mi piace o sensi mi piace
ha raccolto i dati per due anni dopo
questa raccolta di dati ha scritto un
documento accademico un paper che poi è
stato validato dalla comunità
scientifica e ha dimostrato che ci sono
dei comportamenti diversi e gli utenti
che hanno delle piattaforme in cui ci
sono i mi piace dagli utenti in cui non
ci sono i mini piattaforma in cui non ci
sono e i comportamenti sono queste negli
ambienti senza il like succedono quattro
cose che secondo me sono quattro cose
positive
possiamo anche dalla contraria dove ci
sono i like succedono quattro cose
negative nelle menti senza mi piace è
stato dimostrato che diminuisce il tasso
di competizione con gli altri cioè se il
mio amico una persona che ha un supporto
ha fatto un post
questo posto è stato super popolare mi
viene voglia di provare a fare un post
che sia più popolare dell'altro e per
farlo in alcuni casi uso un trucco dei
trucchi come ad esempio l'utilizzo
manipolatori delle emozioni tendo a
ingigantire quello che ho provato
tendono esasperarlo perché perché voglio
cercare di ottenere un riconoscimento
sociale la parte degli altri
negli ambienti senza laiche diminuiscono
i comportamenti di tipo iper reattivo
cioè quella tendenza a rispondere
commenti subito ci viene in mente una
cosa una persona ci fa incazzare gli
rispondiamo immediatamente cosa che
magari nella vita digitale accade più
facilmente rispetto ad altri tipi di
ambiente
e poi negli ambienti senza like
diminuisce la tendenza
l'omogeneizzazione delle posizioni
espresse cosa voglio dire qui torniamo
agli ambienti con i live che online
vedo dieci amici che prendono posizioni
sull'argomento tutti e dieci hanno
ottenuto dei post che hanno fatto
grandissimo successo io la penso
diversamente da loro sapere che questi
dieci persone sono andate molto bene con
i loro post su internet non mi fa venire
voglia di dire la cosa opposta perché ho
paura della reazione degli altri 15 sono
gli esperimenti per vedere cosa succede
se togliamo i like quindi evidentemente
c'è una pressione sociale molto forte
sugli utenti che vivono male la loro
esperienza di navigazione quando parlano
di determinati argomenti la politica e
probabilmente l'argomento che più di
ogni altro crea questo genere di
situazione di ansia di difficoltà nel
manifestare le proprie posizioni
una ricerca di agos del pew research
center un think thank americano dice che
il 46 per cento degli utenti prova
disagio per la quantità e la qualità dei
post che parlano di politica è solamente
il 15 per cento è contento di quello che
sta accadendo
il dato è in crescita gli sci punti
rispetto a tre anni fa quindi molti
utenti ritengono di vedere troppi
contenuti politici social
quindi tornando all'inizio dieci anni fa
ci eravamo detti tutto bene
un'opportunità in più
dieci anni dopo c'è una fuga da questo
tipo di contenuti
quindi oggi chiamati a disagiati
networks l'esperienza del parlare il
politico online con chi la pensa
diversamente sta allontanando le persone
invece di avvicinarle quindi c'è una
cosa che non sta girando come dovrebbe
come ci aspettavamo questo è ancora più
visibile in particolare quando parliamo
di politica con persone che la pensano
diversamente da noi sempre la stessa
ricerca di prima vediamo che il 68 per
cento dei rispondenti a questa ricerca
che era stata fatta sugli utenti social
negli stati uniti dice che le
conversazioni con chi la pensa
diversamente da 6 sui temi politici sono
stressanti e frustranti solamente il 27
per cento le trova interessanti e
informative e dato ancor più grave il 67
per cento dei rispondenti ritiene di
avere meno cose in comune col suo
interlocutore dopo aver fatto di su
questa discussione quindi il confronto
online non solo non ci sta avvicinando
ma ci sta allontanando dalle persone con
cui la pensiamo diversamente
quindi sta succedendo questo non era
previsto ripeto quando iniziato a fare
questo lavoro
i social media nella loro configurazione
attuale spingono comportamenti
disadattivi da parte degli utenti li
abbiamo visti prima quei quattro
elementi di distorsione e la discussione
politica allo stato attuale genera
sentimenti negativi cioè quindi un
problema piuttosto grande con la
comunicazione politica che va risolto
quindi ripeto tornando un attimo
indietro da consulente ma prima di tutto
da cittadino mi chiedono costantemente
perché siamo arrivati qui e come ne
veniamo fuori perché chiaramente la
discussione politica così polarizzata
racconta molto della fase che stiamo
vivendo a livello nazionale a livello
internazionale e sono tornato ancora più
indietro quindi non solo i dieci anni fa
hanno iniziato a fare questo lavoro
ma quando iniziato l'università io sono
laureato in psicologia e al primo anno
primo semestre esame di psicologia
generale primo capitolo del libro c'era
la spiegazione delle cosiddette emozioni
primarie chi ha visto inside out
ora una conoscenza molto maggiore le
emozioni primarie in psicologia sono
queste sei felicità tristezza paura e
disgusto arrabbia e sorpresa fate mente
locale pensando alla comunicazione
politica online quale di queste emozioni
primarie sono evocate più spesso quelle
centrali
la paura la rabbia e disgusto c'è sempre
l'attacco contro l'altro la
demonizzazione del diverso cioè sempre
la stereotipizzazione della minoranza
c'è sempre qualcuno che è più cattivo di
qualcun altro c'è sempre il penultimo
contro l'ultimo ed è così giorno per
giorno dopo giorno dopo giorno ed è
questo che è il motore di quello che
abbiamo visto prima per fortuna qualcuno
si è reso conto che questa storia non
può andare più avanti
john major e stato premier nel regno
unito nei primi anni 90 e dello stesso
partito di boris johnson l'attuale
premier e l'attuale premier sta gestendo
la situazione della break sit in modo
assolutamente scrive tari altro dal
punto di vista della comunicazione
politica al punto di vista politico
possiamo aprire un dibattito infinito
dal punto di vista della comunicazione
sta correndo un rischio molto grande
cioè sta polarizzando costantemente sta
costantemente esasperando il discorso
per cercare di creare consenso su di sel
che cerca di utilizzare questa
situazione assurda per provare a vincere
le prossime elezioni già meglio
in un discorso di tre settimane fa che
io trovo strepitoso e soprattutto perché
mosso da una persona del suo stesso
partito ad calato a bordi amo il
linguaggio di divisione di odio parole
come sabotatore tradimento nemico resa
sono parole che non dovrebbero avere
alcuno spazio nel nostro partito si
rivolgeva suo premier al suo capo di
partito per dire signori attenzione qui
non possiamo più andare avanti perché
rischiamo veramente di sfasciare tutto
nei giorni cioè potresti forse vincere
le prossime elezioni ma le macerie che
lascerai alla reputazione del regno
unito del partito conservatore a lungo
periodo saranno incalcolabili
quindi qui vedo un piccolo segnale del
fatto che forse siamo arrivati a un
punto limite al punto di vista del
linguaggio politico in italia e non solo
come dicevo quando abbiamo iniziato a
utilizzare la comunicazione i social in
comunicazione politica ci aspettavamo
che rappresentasse in un altro modo
invece la situazione è questa qui la
fiducia nei partiti del parlamento non è
cresciuta nonostante ci siano 30 milioni
di tag su facebook nonostante politici
siano ovunque ci dicono ogni giorno il
loro pensiero non c'è non si ricrea
rapporto di fiducia
l'astensionismo continua a crescere
salvo rarissime occasioni quindi
all'allontanamento nonostante i social
commenta in italia prevale la sfiducia
nel futuro nonostante appunto tutti gli
spazi di democrazia che in teoria si
sarebbe dovuto aprire agli utenti che
parlano di politica online risultano più
stressati di prima quindi abbiamo siamo
partiti da un dubbio adesso diventa
anche parte della soluzione
abbiamo analizzato lo abbiamo fatto una
domanda c'è stata l'analisi di che cosa
sta succedendo qui c'è la mia difficoltà
più grande quando faccio questo mese
moltissime persone mi dicono soprattutto
clienti persone che mi chiedono così io
faccio una cosa così bella ma prendo 5
like su facebook perché che cosa succeda
sta subentrando piano piano del vero
veleno per chi fa il mio mestiere l'idea
che si possa comunicare solo come trump
ho solo come vendola non solo come
salvini cioè che è la rabbia il disgusto
e la paura siano le uniche strade per
ottenere consenso online per ottenere mi
piace per ottenere condivisione dei
contenuti
questo è il mio nemico più grande l'idea
che si possa fare solo così e che si
debba polarizzare estremizzare
continuamente sollecitare l'opinione
pubblica costantemente inondarla di
pensieri negativi sentimenti negativi
per questo motivo noi abbiamo fatto un
esperimento abbiamo fatto a cielo aperto
lo abbiamo fatto nella mia città
bari durante l'ultima tornata di campali
le elezioni nel 2019 lavorando con il
sindaco in carica che è stato rieletto
antonio decaro e abbiamo deliberatamente
dal primo giorno senza sapere
esattamente come sarebbe andata a finire
ma con con la convinzione che dovevano
perlomeno provarci
abbiamo messo un anomalia del sistema in
un sistema in cui la comunicazione
politica online in italia per come la
pensiamo e da immaginiamo si basa
sostanzialmente su rabbia paura
abbiamo letto utilizziamo altre due
emozioni primarie delle sei che abbiamo
visto quelle positive
la speranza e la c'è la sorpresa e la
gioia abbiamo fatto alcune cose che
ripeto il solitamente non si fanno
non abbiamo fatto nessuna polemica
politica sui social se voi andate oggi
sulla pagina di decaro andate a scorrere
a ritroso all'ultimo anno e mezzo di
post troverete forse 23 contenuti che
hanno a che fare con temi che non siano
le strade della città
i rifiuti e inaugurazioni dei parchi la
mobilità eccetera eccetera
non c'è stato nessun attacco frontale
agli avversari devo gli avversari ci
hanno aiutato perché erano piuttosto
debole un po ipocrita e soprattutto
abbiamo sistematicamente utilizzato le
emozioni positive in campagna elettorale
abbiamo cercato di rispondere la domanda
iniziale si può fare si vincono le
elezioni contenuti positivi sono virali
la risposta è stata sì si può fare
adesso sto per farvi vedere con l'aiuto
della regia eccola qui che entra così il
contenuto più virale di tutta la
campagna elettorale per le
amministrative a bari nel 2019
[Musica]
4 butta da colpe di deca
sono le sette del mattino la bocca
impastata di sabbia dal balcone del
vicino a riva nebbia e il suo soffitto
dici poco anche rabbia e valpadana
mattonella giusta
la ricetta e copia incolla da internet
ma non si crede un master chef cole
phelps si sente cranko movado sopra i
cavalli e la spa con la sola dell'ante
aderente ma si sa ma attacca quelle vite
ma niente il malumore lombadia prendo
brioschi ma i fiaschi e mi resta sullo
stomaco mi viene il vomito faccio un
caffè in bilico il barattolo di zucchero
mi cade sul parquet reciclo schiere e
ciò perché sennò cafè rimane amaro nel
destino cinico e baro come l'ho pensato
che lo dico fa rubar
la colpa di chi è la colpa di deca la
colpa
[Musica]
c'è sempre lunedì la colpite cresco
allora strozzino i soldi per chi come te
stesso team a mente lo faccio su pc cast
e nero su facebook almeno così è scritto
a durazzo con la faccia di un carlino
contro il pezzo di focaccia ma il
pomodorino brucia la mia lingua spero
che la razza to assistiti insieme a
quella pazza della vigilessa che di
stanca perché il mio sogno l'ho messo
sulle strisce ma non capisce che con gli
stessi di occupato ieri sera è già un
miracolo che lo lascia pulito sullo
scivolo all'amat al diavolo fa verbale
finisce male allora chiamo consigliere
comunale amico migratori mista multa e
dico io ma non su su capossela si stile
lacapagira mi dice serie ucciso decine
euro e io chiedo votata a fare alle
elezioni se mango le contravvenzioni può
levare queste ti col gas e il solito
cazzaro però sola con la colpa di chi è
[Musica]
la colpa
colpe di teca se cani del quartiere la
fanno tutti qui la colpite l'erba del
vicino sa troppo di hc la colpi di testa
gran la figlia di fantozzi e taylor
swift e melo su facebook
carmelo così cittadino carlo c'è ragione
sono dei casi la causa di ogni tua
preoccupazione c'è la pensionati fa
mordere il cuscino
se la tua donna se la facoltà bocchino
la colpa è mia
per tutto quel che ti succede la colpa
mia se la tua squadra nel proscenio
fanta casa se fa caldo se fa freddo se
fa tiepido se il treno fa ritardo se si
allenti così al muro dove né il sibilo è
colpa mia ma sai a maggio sanno le
elezioni se non mi voti se non vinco
come le spiegherà i test e delusioni si
può verde analisi e psicoterapeuti con
san carlo è molto più economico
un classico più comodo più chiavi dire
che è colpa di re caccia lions dire che
è colpa di de caro dire che è colpa di
recente ha colpe di decade kardec
artecard è fatta la musica sa di che la
cosa vai
[Musica]
questo video nasce da una situazione
politica reale cioè un consigliere
comunale di opposizione nei mesi
precedenti all'uscita di questo video ha
tappezzato bari diverse campagne in cui
attribuiva de caro la responsabilità di
qualsiasi cosa andrà all aeroporto in
vendita la fiera del levante che il
rischio fallimento
la cittadella della giustizia che non
andava non è ancora stata insediata
quindi responsabilità in alcuni casi che
afferivano effettivamente
l'amministrazione comunale altri casi
che afferiva una regione al governo a
chiunque altro questo tormentone colpa
di dakar colpo di decaro potevamo
affrontarlo o rispondendo a limone con
livore o batte controbattendo giorno
dopo giorno poi compone mica oppure
affrontandolo in altro modo con l'arma
dell'ironia ed ha funzionato anche
internet o più numerici positivo è stato
virale ci ha fatto vincere le elezioni
c'e infatti vinci rumor sorprendente
nell'ordine di grandezza infatti de caro
ha ottenuto 30 mila voti in più rispetto
a cinque anni fa e ha ottenuto 56 mila
voti da elettori che in quello stesso
momento
entrando nelle urne per votare per
votare l'europea hanno votato una
coalizione diversa da quella che lo
sosteneva cioè il centrosinistra ci
hanno votato o centrodestra o 5 stelle
quindi c'è stato uno spostamento di voti
fortissimo a vantaggio del sindaco
questa la differenza europee
la coalizione regalo tanto in 32 al 3
per cento dei consensi male carotenuto
36 punti percentuali in più della sua
coalizione anche grazie secondo noi a
questo metodo di lavoro completamente
diverso e di anomalia rispetto a quello
che in italia solitamente siamo abituati
a osservare arriviamo alle conclusioni
molto rapidamente la discussione online
sulla politica oggi non funziona dircelo
è il modo migliore per andare oltre e
affrontare il problema
chi vince le elezioni usando la paura e
la rabbia forse vince le elezioni domani
e dopodomani forse ce la fa fra cinese
ma causa danni permanenti alla qualità
del dibattito pubblico perché qui i
numeri che abbiamo visto nelle ricerche
sono figli di anni di stimolazione della
l'opinione pubblica attraverso
sentimenti negativi
è importante spezzare questa spirale
dimostrando oggi ci ho provato nel mio
piccolo che si può comunicare con
successo anche utilizzando le emozioni
positive e chiuderebbero dicendo che se
è vero che il grosso della
responsabilità sulla qualità scadente
dal dibattito pubblico e soprattutto sul
fatto che gli esseri umani cominciano
presenti si è stressati a parla di
politica e dei politici e di chi li
aiuta
e anche vero che ciascuno di noi nel suo
piccolo può provare a invertire la
spirale cercando di introdurre emozioni
positive nel proprio discorso sia
pubblico che privato sia offline che
online grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]